en estas imágenes grabadas por un grupo
de ucranianos varios tanques rusos
avanzan hacia kiev
en este vídeo unos tanques atacados se
escucha un soldado ruso el comandante
del batallón ha sido asesinado su
superior le pide un reporte fuimos
atacados por la artillería tanques y
drones en el suelo un soldado ucraniano
graba uno de los tanques destruidos eso
es lo que pasa cuando vienes a
territorio ucraniano esta región de
burberry está efectivamente el nuevo
frente al este de kiev los soldados su
cara nos siguen manteniendo el control
del último tramo de la autopista de
escribir pero los rusos están a sólo 40
kilómetros de la capital ucraniana
siguiendo con su asedio en los últimos
dos días este hospital de ebro barrio
vio unos 30 heridos llegar como este
soldado ucraniano que fue sorprendido
por el ejército ruso
unos soldados estaban sentados en un
tanque empezaron a disparar
inmediatamente cuando nos vieron después
el tanque llegó hacia nosotros mi amigo
fue herido y el tercer chico no
sobrevivió
en el pueblo cercano de bélica de merck
a los civiles sufren los bombardeos
constantes
hemos sido atacados cinco veces aquí una
vez en techo y también allá al otro lado
de kiev y pina aprovecha de un periodo
de calma para evacuar a la población
dios donde me están llevando los ciclos
de martín y mo acabamos de pasar 14 días
en el sótano sin agua ni calefacción
pero regresaremos no hay duda yo busco
poder
al menos 1000 personas lograron huir de
espn